gentlemen it's time for battle it's time
for a war in Europe I'm not talking
about current events i'm talking about a
via games coming out in a couple of
months battlefield one you guys were
getting access apparently to the closed
alpha which does gameplay popping up all
over the place at the moment yeah but
you guys played a bunch during e3 and I
haven't had a chance to talk to you guys
about it yet oh yeah so I'm intrigued I
actually don't think we ever did like a
post impressions of it we kind of uh if
you like a three video featured three
four video features three four written
things yeah I think I wrote but publish
like for previews we didn't have a
chinwag about it exactly between between
battlefield fans yeah so I guess I've to
ask Rob first of all what did you play
what were they showing off and how long
did you play it on uh we played conquest
on that Matt basically the livestream
they showed off after their press
conference is Snoop Dogg 420 you know it
okay no pot smoking in this one but oh
my gosh kick butt yeah we played
conquest Mike and I played I think we
play like two matches they kind of cut
them a little short right um we played
another mode which are not supposed to
talk about yet but it's it's in the
closed alpha but we did play like a
second it's not even a different mode
really yeah that's embarrassing played a
bunch of both and played a lot two hours
total we were there the whole weekend
was two hours total I think he played
more but you might have gotten like
three or four matches an or something
alright let's talk about how it felt
down there so I guess on the ground
infantry does it feel like that I feel
for does it feel familiars does it feel
like a like the jump we got between two
and three it definitely feels like a
more different era I mean the bullet
travel times a little different I mean I
was like just like then battlefield 3
and 4 I was I was sniping a good deal
the time as a scout and I had to leave
my targets I was missing for a while at
first but then I got a little better
toward the end um yeah it feels very
much it does feel like a world war two
game right so world war two the weapons
you see in here were around during World
War one to speak historically about it
but they were more like prototypes or
like elite squads we're kind of
experimenting with them but the count it
feels very much like a there's a lot of
weight to the guns as battlefield is one
to do the actual time to kill is pretty
mean I
someone with a sniper rifle they're
either dead or I had to hit him once
more hmm it felt it felt really good i
mean we're on mouse and keyboard which I
don't for Battlefield games I don't
traditionally or I mean I used to but
I've been so a custom of controllers
lately that it actually felt good that
one mouse and keyboard aside from when I
was in vehicles then it became a little
unwieldy yeah it's really hard to fly
playing with a mouse right yeah yes i
found out i'm looking around here
joystick all day today yeah i have them
you found it found it okay good you had
it typical so let's talk about some of
the vehicles in and i respect to jump
into any their planes when you were
there oh you know it i got i was able to
get a taste for each one of them and
Mike and I acts are doing a little
feature unlike what is different about
the air combat and it is probably the
most exciting part for at least for me
and as far as all the games go
battlefield series they're really
diversifying roles you play yes like
Pryor you had like you know your your
strict air combat dog fighting planes
and as always you had like a ground
attack plan yeah here you have that as
well bombers attack lanes with turrets
and fighters which are very much like
agile you're doing loops around bombers
with turrets and I think one of the
biggest things is takeaway is that this
time around which really changes the dog
fighting game is that bombers have two
turrets no longer in my opinion what
you'll see is no longer can i attack a
bomber like a classic behind the six
yeah he I got shred immediately by that
back turret right so now you have this
fighter class that's right the triplane
yeah I killed him you have the triplane
which is so agile and it almost is
tasked it's like a sniper plane but it's
so agile it's meant to basically I think
do loops and get underneath these
bombers right cannot attack bombers now
right from behind us behind they're
coming from underneath them from the
side 0 exactly get get unpredictable for
these church because these shirts can
rip these planes part and so how many
people are in some of these plans then
bombers have three so the front turret
back turret three max right we had any
planes with yeah I think there was
either
three or less so they all they kind of
work like the tanks do then you've got
like a driver and somebody on tours oh
yeah oh yeah that's cool did you guys
jump into the tanks at all I didn't I I
did like an armored car so it was like a
car with like a few side turrets but
they're like the main turn on top and
just owe those people cuz like again the
dynamic weather sets in right you can't
see anything it's so foggy so people
just like making a blind corner and I'm
just added a checkpoint just hosing down
guys that was a really fun aspect of it
that's where the destruction else comes
into play the footage playing right now
is I crawled into this attic of a
farmhouse trying to look for a good
vantage point and I had this tiny window
but all of a sudden a tank just hit the
place and tore off the wall so oh there
we go and I kind of just held out here
for a while but at the destruction I
mean with when you combine the actual
aerial combat with the ground combat
because we were talking before the in
terms of being historically accurate
these planes I have no idea how close
they are I'm not like in an aviary
expert of that period but they are
slower so you can't dogfight right you
can come up from below bombers like you
were saying which you probably wouldnt
want to do if they are bombing at the
time but um they're actually the bombers
are tied to the ground combat in such a
way that like at one point when the fog
rolled in I had a flair and like oh
that's what this is for the bomber
couldn't see the ground didn't know like
where people worse I got a flare up yeah
that's why they have it for so I I was
wishing he was in the bomber because we
didn't have like had microphones with
the other people at the event but I shot
a flare up and like Oh that'd be perfect
if I was like Rob see that flare just
bond that area I'm gonna get out of
there it's a control point you'll take
care of it the fog is actually pretty
intense I would say it mean for an alpha
game they probably want to tone it back
because yeah you're flying around you
cannot see jack yes you can t see
buildings or anything or nothing terrain
just the icons on your on your mini-map
right like just like here's kind of
where a is but it's just white if you
free on the ground to the fog just makes
the entire battle close quarters but I
also used it for an opportunity to
charge across this open field that we
couldn't cross before cuz there's like
three Scouts covering it can you take at
the planes done from the ground yeah you
can Rob know as you can because I did
him back and forth moments yeah he would
watch they showed it just earlier I
killed him he killed me and so I took
him down I was a
I took him down and he's a bomber and
then I was flying a bomber and he it's
true so this is really great so this is
again like what makes this game so
awesome is that vehicle especially an
error you take personal damage as well
as vehicle damage so he straight up I
would like review the footage he
straight up for the machine gun shot me
out as a pilot in the head I died
immediately what's the vehicle took like
three percent damage the way it was shot
was perfectly at the plane leading know
a nice and then I was like behind a
building and then I was like okay
thinking said I gotta kill so I went to
the other side a look and then on the
other side the plane was like plummeting
to the ground and then I got the gunner
killer and then he gets the gutter girl
because all yeah I had a front gunner it
was probably like hey what's going on so
he blows a diver in he gets that kill um
I want to touch on also is like another
new aspect of these vehicles is this is
incredible to me is that for the first
time depending on where I take down a
bomber say I shoot up his right wing
who's right engine that affects the
controls oh really oh yeah so my right
ear on goes out I'm now constantly
battling the tip of fellow Wow just as a
tank you can take out the left like
treads of a tank now it can't turn in
circles yeah exact can you like comedy
make of like cuz i know you can sort of
mess with the terrain as well there's
any way of like crazy like an improvised
like trench that the tank would fall
into or something uh yeah so one thing
that he had noticed well to get into the
airship later the behemoths but I this
is sort of along those lines I was
telling him I might have talked about
this already maybe not in the lobby yet
but um artillery came and there's like
but you know it's 64 player battles so
there's like five other guys with me
defending this outpost of a sudden we
hear like whistling really oh my god
artillery just pounds us I'm the only
one of the five of the six alive I'm
like half dead but the artillery created
craters so I crawled into one I didn't
fire a shot for like 45 seconds but I
held out inside the zone for long enough
for my team to get back with armored
trucks and just come out like gods I
didn't have a medic nearby either but um
in terms of creating will cover uh guess
like the behemoth is a good example like
what you showed me earlier which I
didn't know was possible with the yeah I
went into the reddits and leg found out
all these things so there are the
undercarriages of the behemoth like
people are kind of two behemoths through
I'm sorry the big giant Zeppelin then
blows up in the end you can take out the
they're calling them the gondolas which
is where the pilots and the Gunners
reside right people were originally
shooting like the actual blimp itself
which is fine you're doing damage but
your actual role is to take out these
gondolas so for instance the front
gondola is where the pilot who dropped
bombs and has two side Gunners you're
taking out that guy because what it does
is now for the respawn length of the
gondola coming back it's the blend is
now inoperable as far as pilot and can't
drop bombs right or those two Gunners
are not like knocking the gondola off oh
oh it's joy so high security dude it
falls down and then creates a secondary
explosion on the ground destroys things
craters decimate whoever's below it so
with the pilot I wonder what it looks
like from their perspective that a just
like you control of the thing and that
it just Falls I would imagine he dies
immediately actually I think he does
that would be great but I mean he's
probably still spawn in it and maybe
you're spawning eyes it's falling who
knows that's nom yeah and that like even
touches on I was playing battlefield 4
last night like yes there's some
destructible environment like just the
side walls of buildings and I think sir
some buildings go down but like I take
was shooting me and like I was still
able to like hide in a building right
and take cover not in this game like you
are leveling buildings you you run into
a barn you're not safe you know like a
tank and just busting the front door
yeah and kill you it's just you got like
awesome I mean they said they said
producer alex Crandall at e3 they're not
trying to make a documentary so yeah if
you're expecting completely maybe the
campaign will be more historically
accurate and they could tell like the
unsung stories of like you know like the
Harlem Hellfighters young but in
multiplayer they're taking liberties
just to make it a fun game they
definitely seem to be trying to have the
cake and eat it without work yeah look
we have all this historical World War
One stuff but also I mean Yolo yeah
since the reveal their pen a tone back
on the the setting like using that as a
marketing device yeah more because you
have mustard gas but they're like
grenades you throw and it's actually
pretty cool though I mean in terms of
how it works it
like a just like a poison gas grenade
and if you run into it you'll die within
like two seconds if you don't but
everybody has a gas mass used tapti
keyboard you'll throw your gas mess on
your field of view will become more
narrow and I'll you'll have like
blinders on the sound effects of this
game in general or unreal exactly
between yeah it's dice and then like
it'll become muffled but you'll run into
the smoke you or them up the gas and
just start like I had a submachine at
one point and got like four kills took
the pillows just cuz I had mustard gas
another thing about the behemoth is like
having reviewed the footage is you know
this thing comes down and it's just
wreckage the shell of this thing you
could essentially because the halfway
through the game or it's not confirmed
yet but for the beta or the Alpha sake
halfway through the losing team gets
that Zeppelin yeah it's coming down as a
pilot so no matter what they get it they
think because it's so this I kinda weird
think it's that same mode specifically
but it's also not always half way it's I
think there's a certain point where
they're like okay this team's getting
smoked they need it right I think it's
actually a ticket gap right if they're
getting crushed over say 50 or something
I hear like a game show yeah okay yeah
yeah you just gets a great contest I'm
really big one anyways as a pilot hey I
got five seconds before this thing blows
I you know we're losing still hmm i have
a capture point that's mine and the
Germans are coming in there and they're
gonna completely overrun it why not
position my blimp separating the
opposing team and basically creating a
giant a trench or something role of
skeleton frame spacing on each obstacle
round Mike my own team West boy like
that's totally what you could do because
it takes like a while you can't just
like run through this wreckage you're
dropping help me sleep on these yeah
like I'm so people just trying to get
over it so you think again like that's a
strategic device I think I'm coming down
which is really great oh and supposedly
did reviewing the footage again this is
great is supposedly as it's going down
and then I went back and looked at
because i read i saw in a read a comment
there is a dude running up the top of
the blimp has for falling down i think
is one guy
you see is printing up with like a wall
of flame following him supposedly you
can you can't make it out dude it goes
down you can ride it down because the
top part of it actually doesn't ever
catch flame oh right supposedly like
someone was able do it was was to jump
off the last second it cuz you can like
that you does everyone have a pair of
shoes yeah it's like it yourself
quickfire shoot button like the gun I
think so which that's just another one
of those things that makes a game more
fun because you could just whoever you
are I can jet out like overweight like
what you did you might have mentioned
this you were in the plane jumped out of
the plane onto the airship right and
then afterward parachute out of the
airship once you were over like one of
the O's you just keep pulling that thing
yeah wait so you got like 17 preserve
shoots under back last battlefield oh
yeah that I mean yeah and in the
behemoth was interesting too because
like I had to leave it because the guy
was piloting it was a [ __ ] he was a
going on out of the map and I'm a slide
to it I can't move i'm just like
shooting off map yeah I'm out of here I
don't know so it's it's just interesting
to see what were these things are gonna
go a lot of questions here at Diablo sex
saying pity zeppelin confirmed that's
pretty good and I don't like multiplayer
awards based off of killstreaks as Bob
Jones 1980 did you see any insight into
what they were looking out for unlocks
and one not like character progression
was was there any that stuff in relation
to the weaponry there were a lot of
weapons unlike last though okay yeah
only like four or five reach class but
then you could see ten more were
unlockable and these are weapons that
are typically associated with one class
so you had a whole bunch of weapons with
but there will be attachments and
customization options right yes like
mosin nagant would like the Russian
sniper rifle with a German sniper but
then there were already attachments to
it I'm pretty sure for the purpose of
our event we didn't see the progression
but we got the rewards right away like
we like it was just they were all
outfitted the guns were all outfitted
yeah when and then you can even
definitely take a look at the whatever
that that pre-ordered DLC they had which
like Red Baron right so you're
customizing your planes as well and they
made a big deal of the Honda hand stuff
in the trailer did you guys implement
that at all did you find yourselves just
shooting
I got Bayonetta like six times I don't
know I wasn't even sure how people are
doing it because that not every weapon
has it been that but I tried it it's
that's it actually people have been like
discussing like whether or not like
how's this gonna work is it gonna work
say you and I both charged bayonet that
the same time here's a war stories I
counter there is a counter there is a
counter yeah exactly i think there's a
Mythbusters at some youtuber day night
he said that if I I basically if known
or take you down if your bait we're
banning it Bayonetta each other I have
to be the last one to engage it right so
basically if I see you rushing me with
it and I go I'll take you down mm-hmm so
not gonna shot you in the face it's good
point the bullet is mightier than the
sword how's the old saying goes yeah any
other thoughts anything a little we
didn't didn't catch up on I didn't see
it you guys experienced it but we just
love how and this could go two ways I
think of them today but I just love how
there aren't lock on missiles there
aren't like all these future modernistic
approaches to war that like this is just
again like a call back to like
battlefield 1942 which likes skill yes
like lead the shots figure out where to
shoot I mean now you're getting even
more specifically out with planes like
okay I shoot the engine was already shot
him yeah that's amazing look it's just
coming I just think it's a call back to
nineteen forty-two and that it's like
bring back the skill just how I felt
with like how halo kind of yeah try that
with the new one like less hits can
weapons more just like you kind of have
to like aim the shot and ya be true what
do you think Mike any any last thoughts
on it excited first yeah I'm really
excited like I said it and I was
initially disappointed at how much of a
world war two game it felt but then I
played for like two hours and it's fun
and I wasn't expecting like they said I
documentary yeah the pronunciation of
which I get made fun of what I was
always literally about to say that was
really where heat Brown calls me out
yeah that's a tangent man Terry it's
documentary it's elementary school you
don't say secretary so how well you do
if you live in europe sorry second top
for a walk your entry what was the other
one everyone is wrong secretary
secretary secretary secretary saying you
say secretary secretary I say secretary
is trying to prove a point now
and what was the middle one elementary
school say primary school does my
primary she lost mad about every calls
herself marrow yeah I guess she let
Murray Murray no Murray Alfie one's
really fun I'm excited for it Marie it's
been a long two weeks agogames fought
off sorry Marie our very own Murray is
coming over the voice of God saying to
wrap it up thank you both I don't have
the same thing as me documentary it's
like a guy called Terry who makes stuff
sorry Mary okay let's wrap it up that's
file feel one I will be putting up a
bunch of battlefield one stuff i'm
guessing over the next couple of days a
lot the bar goes over soon so expect
some battlefield one stuff early next
week so I be this in okay I can start
putting up step right in the Alpha God
okay tuesday / video features hitting a
spot i can be a long way again yeah yeah
so check out games felt a comment
youtube.com for Sasuke spot